INTERVIEWER: Hot air balloons
have been around for centuries.
But, I've got to say, I
don't really get them.
I like heights, but I'd
rather just go skydiving.
I really don't understand what's
compelling about the scene,
but apparently 140,000
people disagree with me.
Hopefully the photographer
can help us out
with these big, possibly
pointless, floating enigmas.
CHRISTOPHER CHANG: Hi.
My name is Christopher Chang.
By day, I lead
strategy and operations
in the high-tech industry.
And in my spare time, I'm
an amateur photographer.
This photo was taken in Reno,
Nevada not long after sunrise.
But the event actually started
hours earlier in the day
at pre-dawn.
INTERVIEWER: What
we're looking at
is the Great Reno Balloon Race,
one of the largest balloon
races in the world.
It's been an annual
celebration since 1982.
And each year, 140,000
people from around the world
come to watch more than
100 unique balloons
fill the Nevada sky.
CHRISTOPHER CHANG:
This photo captures
what the hot air
balloon race organizers
call the mass ascension launch,
where all the balloons take off
as the main event of the race.
And it is quite the spectacle as
all the balloons fill the sky.
INTERVIEWER: The sheer
scale of the mass ascension
is almost worth the
trip in and of itself.
But for Christopher, that's
not even the best part.
CHRISTOPHER CHANG: One of
the fun aspects of this race
is watching all the fun-shaped
balloons take to the sky.
There are so many great
experiences at this event,
but if I have to
pick a favorite,
it is seeing the dawn patrol
getting ready and take off
to the still, dark sky.
Watching these fully-lit and
colorful balloons drift off
in the pre-dawn is
an incredible sight.
The dawn patrol
features only a handful
of balloons that are
qualified to fly in the dark.
And it's incredible to watch
these balloons glow brightly
in the dark as they
prepare to take off.
INTERVIEWER: And,
honestly, after looking
at all these pictures,
I think I get it.
Hot air balloons don't
need to be practical.
They're just cool to look at.
And sometimes it's that simple.
No one needs to know the
science behind fireworks
to enjoy them, or understand
astronomy to stargaze.
Sometimes it's enough
just to look up and enjoy.
CHRISTOPHER CHANG:
This was my first--
and so far, only-- visit to
the Great Reno Balloon Race.
It's definitely in my plans
to go back for another visit.
I would definitely recommend
this event to everyone.
INTERVIEWER: If you
liked this episode,
be sure to check out this one.
On this island prison
that's also a national park,
strangely enough.
SUBJECT: These photos
were taken on a flight
from Key West, Florida to
Fort Jefferson, Dry Tortugas.
Access to the island can only
be done by sea plane or by boat.
Our plane was not equipped
for landing on the water,
so I enjoyed an afternoon of
picture taking from the air.
INTERVIEWER: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.